welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode 8 rise of the new
maricons the movie let's break down this
episode shop by shop for all the Easter
eggs hidden animation details and inside
jokes that you might have missed and
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform that makes
launching your own website a breeze this
episode picks up with the post credit
sequence of the Season 2 Episode get
schwifty and that episode IC tea voiced
by Dan Harmon teams up with Rick and
Morty to write a song to please some
giant B heads who keep yelling show me
what you got episode ice te reveals
himself to really be an Alien named
water tea from a planet called alphab
betrium where everyone is a letter and
also sometimes an element in the
post-credit scene he returns to his home
which is under attack by the new
maricons the episode ends with the title
card this summer water tea and the rise
of the new maricons in a font that kind
of looks like it's from the Transformers
movies and this episode is that movie
and Morty's in it we've actually known
this episode was coming for a while now
and animatic for it was shown during the
Rick and Morty panel at ComiCon 2023
this episode ends with kind of a replay
of that sequence we saw in the post
credits for Swifty with some new stuff
thrown in we get this exterior shot for
the big government building on alphab
betrium we see buildings shaped like a G
and F with it looks like an i in the
background there's some sort of Death
Star looking space station with rings
and upside down a which could be a
turned a which would stand for for all
this could be a kind of unity message
for the people of alphab betrium we see
a k with a Dopey looking face and the
Greek letters of Omega and fi so I guess
really any letter in any language can
appear on this planet just not numbers
and also little detail to the left of
the K there is an ugaritic uniform of
this letter which stands for X water te
greets his Elders magnesium J hydrogen F
and father who is magma Q they all have
staffs with different gems on top that
just kind of float beside them water
says he's ready to rejoin his Brethren
and they turn him back into his original
form water tea and then the new maricons
attack now Dan Harmon still sounds like
he's doing the voice of IC teaw waterer
tea here but the actual ice tea is in
the credits of the episode thinking ice
tea is playing his father magma Q so it
sounds like they just re-recorded magma
Q's lines with IC tea and I just love
that all he had to say was take this
thing it's a prophecy or some the
num maricons come down in a calculator
ship that of course has 58008 on the
screen which we learned in fourth grade
Spells at boobs when you turn it upside
down on the street the citizens include
this baby that is a lowercase bee
because as we learn later all the use of
the society are lowercase also a pet on
a leash that it's a d I guess for dog
but it must be an adult dog because it's
uppercase another shot of the citizens
running show e a n c and L and then a
line of C's so I don't know that's kind
of an anagram for cancel like either
this episode being so crazy might get
the show canceled or you know other
people involved with the show got
canceled in otherwise the Mother Ship
releases a TIE fighter but these ships
are shaped like you know number signs or
hashtags it's one of many Star Wars
references in this episode brick and
Morty has done a ton of Star Wars stuff
over the years magma Q gives water te
this necklace with a prophecy on it it's
a gold cylinder with the equation a tbz
CZ he dies and then drops a mic that he
definitely did not have earlier and I
like how hydrogen F tries to cover his
face with a hanky but it just burns up
of course it does he's magma water T
goes out to Crunch the numbers which was
the last line of the schwifty post
credit scene but everything else is new
from here on out water te wrecks shop to
an ass kicking hair metal theme song He
shoves a one through the hole of a nine
and then he picks up two cables and
because he is water he is a natural
conductor of electric current and he
uses this to activate the bracket shield
around the planet and these brackets are
specifically braces or curly brackets
when we see the view of the planet from
space the land masses all the continents
are shaped like letters he jumps on a
ship called the glyph Jumper piloted by
lithium P who of course can't help but
make p jokes water says that they need a
math expert to decode the prophecy even
though it's very very simple and he
knows of a math expert on Earth and we
assume water tea would mean Rick but no
we hard cut to Morty's math teacher Mr
goldenfold which is really interesting
because after 78 episodes this is the
first episode of the series Without Rick
in it which might be why it kind of just
feels a little weird but it makes sense
it's a very simple math equation Rick
would just kind of roll his eyes on this
you have to go to Mr goldenfold and I
like how every time we see this
classroom the math problems on the board
are just ridiculously easy especially
for someone of Morty's grade level
golden bold hears Morty's rap music and
clears the classroom no I want to math
and stuff yeah I love the grumbling from
the class oh I wanted to learn math and
stuff little detail when Morty puts the
apple airpods back into the case I'm
pretty sure he puts them in on the wrong
side so that they're both facing out
also I like a goldenfold calls them
airbuds instead of airpods water T
arrives Morty remembers him from get
Swifty but water T doesn't remember Mr
goldenfold scolds his old student saying
I don't give an ass if you're Smoky
Robinson you got the balls of a clown
coming back to this school yeah smokey
Robinson had a hit with Tears of a Clown
which Mr goldenfold is awkwardly
referencing we flash back to the 80s Mr
goldenfold looks like and is dressed
exactly the same and says without math
Russia would control all the Rubik's
Cubes IC te wears a Pac-Man shirt and
listens to a Walkman but I like how it's
not the Pac-Man character it's just the
word Pac-Man back in the present
goldenfold throws a pendant back at
Water tea I love that it bounces off its
face rather than goes into the water
because I guess their faces are made of
slightly harder stuff than their
Elemental bodies are and yes some of the
alphab betrian also have like minerals
or elements specified and I don't know
that kind of seems like like an upper
class nobility or royalty status but the
new barad's hashtag Fighters or what
they call type Strikers they attack led
by Sinar 7 which is a play on the
Sinister 6 a group of Spider-Man
villains who never seem to make it into
any of the movies no matter how many
times they're set up the glyph jumper
interior has a seating area that looks
like the common room of the Millennium
Falcon Sinar 7 says I see the tales of
your dopeness have been greatly
exaggerated which is a play on the
reports of my death have been greatly
exaggerated a telegram Mark Twain said
to the Press after his obituary was
mistakenly published the typ baced puns
are just abundant this episode lithium P
says Sinar 7 has a cap lock on them and
they escape using the hyphen Drive which
they have instead of a hyperdrive and I
love that this lever has P for Park R
for reverse D for drive and then just a
hyphen for hyphen drive and they later
call it helvetica light speed the new
Baron's Battleship at first looks like
an A or a v which you know that wouldn't
be right but you realize it's actually a
greater than sign which is perfect
because whatever would come to the left
of them they are greater than Sinar 7
reports to her boss a father Lord dreadn
which is a giant zero who appears via
hologram much like the emperor an Empire
Strikes Back or snoke and the force
awakens it gives her an emperor like
shock of Sith lightning while a little
decimal point minion laughs at her
dreadn by the way is also the name of a
Heavy Cruiser class of ship that appears
throughout the Star Wars franchise
goldenfold realizes that the runes are
actually the Pythagorean theorem a squ
plus b sare equal C squ which is brought
up as a kind of shared incestry among
the Deans and the alphabet I suppose
just because it uses letters and numbers
but you know so do a lot of theorems and
equations because algebra and everything
beyond that start using variables and
constants represented by letters it's
knowingly dumb and I love it but hey you
know this theorem like the quadratic
equation it's one of the more beautiful
eurekka of mathematics and like
measuring the distance of the right
triangle hypotenuse it just makes sense
that this Wood Bridge all divides it's
so funny to hear IC tea wrapping out of
rhythm and it requires goldenfold
clapping in 44 time that fixes it like
they actually have him deliberately
wrapping out of 44 time and yes
goldenfold clapping as a mentor a
problematic Mentor reminds me of JK
Simmons's character in Whiplash when he
had to like cruy Clap The Rhythm for mil
teller which is I think the best movie
about a toxic Mentor student
relationship big holiday feasts aren't
just about what's on the table they're
about the whole experience the company
the decorations the vibe for lack of a
better word running an online business
is similar offering a quality product
isn't enough you want to make sure
things are just right and for that
there's Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to do whatever
you need with your website Squarespace
has templates and designs for pretty
much everything so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products then save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business to
check it out for yourself head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com neww rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain the engineer in the studio
picks up the phone and says yo it's
Marvin your cousin Marin D hey you know
that new sound you looking for well
listen to
this yeah total parody of the back to
the future scene where Marvin Barry
calls his cousin Chuck Barry to
supposedly Inspire him to write Johnny
Be Good but this producer just farts
into the phone and I like how Morty
calls him out saying you think chuck
would stop taking his calls and he calls
out goldenfold for even including it in
the story this is my favorite kind of
meta joke like when Homer Simpson tells
his kids how Maggie was conceived we go
from Little Homer cells bumping into an
egg to Homer in the living room
imitating a sperm cell with this crazy
look in his eye goldenfold says the word
boundaries and that's what inspires him
and he says beep as he punches it into
the star map lithium P says E10 is a
mythical planet that they tell lowercase
letters about at bedtime which Morty
also questions why at bedtime which
reminds me of the recent season of
Ahsoka where B and skull is like parido
was a fairy tale like why is it after
Deathly Hallows that all these adult
characters who were supposedly at the
tops of their intelligences in these
fictional universes just lose all
historical record of real places and
things and never ever look into folklore
like an our world Reddit questions
everything and like history and
Discovery Channels have like uh endless
series that look into conspiracy
theories behind nursery rhymes but all
these fictional universes are like no it
was forgotten past the Legends are true
as they bicker lithium P says he's being
punished for clarity and Morty says
punished Jesus I asked a question did
hit what the Yeah I love how this
escalates so fast it's like a spat on
Twitter or Reddit really lithium p is to
water T what Morty is to Rick water te
calls oxygen s who leaves this group of
alphab betrium evacuees that include a k
or an X that looks like it's hairy flesh
water te confirms by pausing and saying
word again with the punts and I love the
design because an S is half of an eight
and then an eight inverted is an
infinity symbol but he kind of looks
like and sounds like Tim Curry which
would remind me of hexus the pollution
based villain character that Curry
voiced in Fern Gully the last rainforest
water T rolls down the window of the
glyph jumper into open space kind of
like he's in a driveby and just shoots
out in open space no worry about Morty
or golden fold inside of that ship they
crashed onto E10 which is a swamp planet
that looks like deoa and notice how the
trees and the roots and the plant life
all take the form of these Twisted
numbers and letters as these would be
the original glyphs that both Neons and
Alpha betri are based on now these
primitive symbols apparently want to
take the gang to their Village for an
Ewok party the Ewok party happened in
the forest Moon of Endor and Return of
the Jedi so I guess this planet just
kind of contains a lot of Star Wars
biomes one of the Primitive symbols
sings Something That kind of sounds like
Jubjub which would be a parody of the
Ewok song yub nuub they are also
roasting a penis-shaped symbol on spit
we'll learn later that these symbols are
kind of like chickens to them so not
quite as brutal as it seems at first
glance we see these symbols crowing
cockadoodle and cockadoodle too you get
it we flash back to the Grammys where is
a guy who kind of looks like Phil
Collins presenting the best hip-hop
award if it is supposed to be Phil
Collins is hilarious that perhaps the
whitest artist of all time is presenting
this particular award but you know
historically the Grammys people like
mmore have snuck in there hey it's not a
value judgment against Bill Collins who
is awesome but you know just objectively
very white earlier in Morty's class last
we see a gothy looking kid with a
t-shirt that says Against All Odds which
was a Bill Collins hit the other
nominees for rap artists of the year are
Will Smith humpty hump and Dr Demento Dr
Demento is the wacky radio DJ who plays
comedy songs who gave Weird Al his start
he did record a rapping promo 1985 but
nothing that I can find from 1991 Will
Smith and DJ Jazzy Jeff were nominated
for best rap performance by a duo or
group Grammy in 1991 Humpty Humps song
The Humpty Dance was nominated for best
rap video at the 1990 MTV video awards I
did win a Grammy though in 1991 for best
rap performance by a do or group for his
appearance on the collaborative song
Back On the Block featuring many artists
and composed by the great Quincy Jones
Sinar 7 arrives at a floating golden
Fortress that reminds me of the golden
lab from the Alex Garland miniseries
devs water T in Sinar 7 appear to be
69ing or doing the best job they can at
it given their Anatomy you'll remember
an extended 69 joke during the post
credit scene of last week's episode with
the squid game VIPs it makes me wonder
what the alpab betrian call this
particular sex act like the num maricons
would call it 69 the alphab Petri would
probably call it like gamma Elling or
something this sequence of their
Consciousness is merging does remind me
of that sequence in the worldly durly
conspiracy episode where Rick and Jerry
and risotto Groupon were Going Through
the Wormhole they have a similar
experience of the shared emotions and
Consciousness we also saw Morty's Crush
Jessica going through this in the season
5 premiere I love anytime Rick Morty
does this CU it's such like an animator
Delight the decimal point says yeah I'm
not even supposed to be here today which
is a famous running joke from Clerks now
the dread knot has a diagonal slash so
that he can never be confused as an O
also the notot in his name is another
word for a zero or nothing I love how
water T is in Chains but they don't
attach to anything he's just imprisoned
because the chains are around him it's
great cartoon logic here water T says
I'm going to shoot you in
the dick I think we're all wondering
what the sex organs are on these
characters especially given the sex
scenes we saw earlier this will get an
explanation later in the episode though
when IC te calls his father his father's
phone is shaped like a j according to
Google Translate this is actually what
it says for the glyph jumper extreme the
spaceship is fast I'm having a lot of
fun right now and then also danger
Infinity says murder death which reminds
me of the murder death kill the police
code from Demolition Man water T wraps
more homicide than a doed decahedron is
a figure with 12 sides I believe the rap
lyrics are why does a one hate an I I
got to wonder when a lowercase i is an
imaginary number imaginary numbers is
something mathematicians invented to be
the square root of negative one who
stands a game when I shoot up the digits
the division is conflict but you know we
got to the vocal scales of whoa more
homicides than a do decahedron number
these letters something Alpha
numerically combined the g c k means my
ice cold nine I got letters and numbers
yeah yeah this is just great water T
asks his returned father if he's like a
force ghost yet had another Star Wars
reference Yoda Anakin other for
sensitive beings often return from dead
as Blue Ghost though daddy Han Solo
returns to kylo Ren or Ben in the rise
of Skywalker but he doesn't glow blue
and Han was never forced sensitive so we
don't really know what he was water t
turns his Enchanted gun sideways before
shooting Infinity the bullet goes under
his head and inside him where it hits
one of two glowing purple orbs which is
apparently his dick after he explodes it
starts to rain little purple Globs which
might be like pieces of it and despite
the fact that he's in his IC tea form he
writes magma te at the top of his test
which still got an F on in the post
credit scene we see that the letters and
numbers are hanging out of each other
there's now a one building next to an a
fortress the clouds in the sky all look
like numbers Ice Cube in ERS and
transforms with a sound that sounds a
lot like the Transformers make when they
transform we learned that this new world
they created is called Alpha numeron and
we slam to a logo for magma te and Ice
Cube in challenge of the geometron which
I'm assuming we'll see sometime around
what season 13 hey big thanks to Jordan
Morris and Brandon Barrett for their
help writing this breakdown I am now
going on paternity leave because our kid
is coming early so for the final two
episodes of the Season friend of the
channel Hector Navaro is going to be
stepping up for hosting duties for Rick
and Morty breakdowns Jessica Clemens is
also back on the channel to help cover
for me while I'm out but you will still
see me a couple times per week in
December in some pre-tape videos that I
think you'll really like I will be back
in a few weeks thanks for supporting new
rock stars and I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
everybody